y coronavirus en francia el costo 158
mil millones de euros esto fue lo que le
costó a francia de coronavirus en 2020 y
el costo solo aumentará según el
gobierno francés el hobbit podría costar
otros 171 mil millones para 2021 y 96
mil millones para 2022
es decir 424 mil millones de euros en
tres años
las pruebas pcr por sí solas costaron
2.200 millones de euros en 2020 pero el
mayor gasto proviene de las
consecuencias de las restricciones
debido a la pandemia algunas empresas
han quebrado y otras se han mantenido a
flote con ayudas estatales el gobierno
francés ha prometido 300.000 millones de
euros como parte de un programa de
préstamos comerciales en garantizados
por el estado al comienzo de la pandemia
muchos de ellos ya se han beneficiado de
los 126 mil millones de euros en 2020 el
gobierno ha prometido destinar 8 mil 200
millones de euros al sector de la salud
pública se destinarán 20 mil millones de
euros
empresas y hogares afectados por la
crisis con los recientes cierres de
tiendas el gobierno anunció nuevas
ayudas por 200 millones de euros para
empresas de cuatro sectores ropa calzado
marroquinería y tiendas deportivas las
medidas fiscales han acompañado todas
estas adaptaciones a las consecuencias
de la pandemia
todo esto plantea interrogantes para el
futuro queda por ver cuánto tiempo el
estado puede mantener la promesa del
presidente de manuel bacón de apoyar al
país como él mismo dijo cueste lo que
cueste